foreign
[Music]
Associated infections continue to be
serious hazards for people engaged in
research or clinical diagnostic work
the magnitude of the problem is Apparent
from data accumulated during the last 50
years
since 1925 some 4 000 reported
infections have endangered the health of
laboratory workers
160 of these infections resulted in
death for the individuals involved
the majority of the laboratory
infections occurred at institutions
engaged in research or clinical
diagnostic work
the people involved were primarily
trained professionals people most
knowledgeable about laboratory hazards
the meaning is clear
infectious hazards can only be reduced
by carefully following appropriate
procedures
this presentation has been prepared to
provide the knowledge you need to reduce
biological hazards in the laboratory
[Music]
of 4 000 cases studied during the past
50 years only 20 percent have been
identified as resulting from known
causes
eighty percent of the cases investigated
resulted from unknown causes
most investigators concluded that
infections from these unknown causes
were due to routine microbiological
procedures including procedures which
resulted in producing aerosols which
contain microbes
these aerosols were found to be the
Principal agents contaminating the
laboratory environment
studies conducted since 1950 suggest
that the following questions must be
considered
what forms do potentially infectious
aerosols take
what factor is determine whether a
laboratory worker becomes infected
what determines the relationship between
these factors
we also need to know what common
microbiological procedures are likely to
generate infectious aerosols
we may also ask what procedures are
likely to be hazardous in work with
experimental laboratory animals
we oppose these questions to add
emphasis to key points to be explored in
this presentation
in identifying aerosols produced by
routine procedures as principal
contaminants of the laboratory
environment two distinct forms have been
described
one kind of aerosol is primarily
composed of large droplets larger than
five microns
the second kind of aerosol consists
mainly of droplet nuclei
these are tiny solid particles whose
usual size is less than five microns
the two forms of aerosols contaminate
the laboratory environment in
contrasting waves
first consider the aerosol composed
primarily of large droplets
these large droplets settle in a
relatively short time and contaminate
work surfaces or skin
the droplet nuclei found in the second
type of aerosol form as a result of
almost instantaneous dehydration
in contrast to large droplets droplet
nuclei May remain indefinitely suspended
in the air drifting about with even
slight air currents
these droplet nuclei may contain only
one or a few microorganisms
four factors determine whether you the
laboratory worker will become infected
by contact with large or small droplet
aerosols
factors determining infection are
extent of contamination
root of infection
virulence of the organism
and host susceptibility
interaction between these four factors
will vary with each pathogen handled
this is why the microbiologists must
have a detailed working knowledge of any
disease producing agent he or she is to
study
the first Factor on our list is extent
of contamination
that is how many microorganisms
contaminate the Air or Surface with
which the microbiologist comes in
contact
these may be measured with air Samplers
or liquid impingers
the second factor is root of infection
the root may be by inhalation ingestion
penetration of the skin or accidental
inoculation
the inhalation or Airborne root occurs
in diseases like tuberculosis
such diseases are spread by inhalation
of bacillin contained within the nuclei
each droplet nucleus is less than 5
microns in size
tuberculosis and other diseases
transmitted primarily by droplet nuclei
are less likely to be of concern when
only surface contamination occurs
ingestion is another frequent root of
infection
salmonellosis shigulosis or other
enteric diseases are commonly spread in
this way
touching contaminated surfaces can
result in finger to mouth transmission
of these infectious agents
penetration of unbroken skin is also an
important root of infection
tularemia is an example of an infection
that may result from penetration of
unbroken skin as well as from accidental
inoculation or inhalation
still another root of infection is
through accidental inoculation which may
occur as a result of animal bites needle
inoculations or punctures by Broken
contaminated glassware
we have explored two of the four factors
determining infection
extent of contamination and route of
infection
the other two factors are virulence of
the organism and host susceptibility
when considering virulence remember that
some infections may be initiated with
one or just a few organisms
others may require large inocula to
initiate infection
finally
host susceptibility will determine the
severity of the illness resulting from
infection
increased resistance to infection can be
achieved through vaccination
we must assure that Personnel are
properly immunized
we have now identified four infection
determining factors
extent of contamination
root of infection
virulence of the organism and host
susceptibility
the importance of these factors varies
from one pathogen to another
we shall now look more closely at the
role of aerosols as a cause of
laboratory infections
potentially infectious aerosols are
formed when common laboratory tools are
used
care must be taken with procedures
involving the inoculating loop
pipette
syringe and needle
frequently aerosols are produced when
the inoculating loop is used to streak
an auger plate having a rough surface
such roughness occurs where bubbles
remained in the agar surface while it
hardened
aerosol formation may be significantly
reduced by using only smooth bubble-free
agar media
the aerosols may be further reduced by
spreading the inoculum with the sterile
bent glass rod
using the bent glass rod reduces
aerosols as much as 65 percent even on
rough auger
the inoculating loop is often sterilized
in the flame of a Bunsen burner
when the hot Loop is immediately touched
to colonies on solid media
or when the hot Loop is inserted into a
liquid microbial culture the sizzling
creates a dangerous aerosol
aerosol formation may be reduced as much
as 99
by allowing the loop to cool before
using it
infectious aerosols also result from the
improper use of pipettes
when the last drop is forcibly expelled
from a pipet the bursting bubble
generates a dangerous aerosol
to minimize this problem drain contents
from the pipette by gravity flow
this reduces aerosol production by as
much as two-thirds
the pipette is frequently used to mix
culture suspensions in a tube
this often results in aerosol generating
bubbles forming at the liquid surface
you may reduce bubble production by
using one of several available test tube
mixers
here mixing is centrifugal forcing
organisms toward the walls of the
container rather than producing bubbles
when the tube is kept closed during
mixing
the nearly saturated atmosphere in the
tube greatly minimizes droplet nuclei
formation
some large droplets however May Escape
as the cap is removed
every microbiologist has at some time
seen a drop of culture suspension fall
from a pipette tip
the amount of potentially infectious
aerosol thus formed varies with the type
of worked surface
the harder the surface the greater the
splatter
you can reduce such aerosols by as much
as 90 percent by placing a towel soaked
in disinfectant on the work surface
procedures involving the syringe and
needle are also potential sources of
aerosols
do not use a syringe as a substitute for
a pipette
accidentally dislodging a needle from a
syringe can be especially dangerous
to prevent this kind of accident use
only locking syringes
when a needle is removed from a rubber
stoppered vial the needle will vibrate
producing an infectious aerosol
wrapping the stopper and needle with
alcohol soaked gauze considerably
reduces these aerosols
expelling air from a partially filled
syringe also creates an aerosol
this procedure should be done only when
the needle is covered with alcohol
soaked gauze
some laboratory procedures require
handling an injection of experimental
animals
laboratory animals should always be
handled by trained personnel
animals must be properly restrained
during inoculation
when animals are inoculated a portion of
the inoculum often leaks back onto the
animal's skin
when the animal is returned to its cage
organisms on the skin contaminate
bedding
these organisms May then be carried
throughout the room on air currents
swabbing the injection site with
antiseptic both before and after
injection will reduce Airborne organisms
by 30 percent
during this presentation we have
explored ways to reduce infectious
aerosols in the laboratory
we have seen how large droplets and
droplet nuclei aerosols are formed in
common laboratory procedures and may
result in contamination
proper use of the inoculating loop
pipette needle and syringe will
significantly reduce this contamination
many infectious incidents stem from the
use of techniques which create aerosols
by reducing aerosols as depicted in this
presentation
you can eliminate many of the infections
that commonly occur in the laboratory
[Music]